&gt;&gt; So now we've seen several curves that look like this and several equations
that have forms similar to this one. So it's important that we talk about what
each of these really are. This kind of curve is called a parabola, and a
parabola is a curve that's produced by equations that have certain features. So
let's talk about what those features are. The equation that produces any
parabola can be written in what's called the standard form for the equation of a
parabola, y equals Ax squared plus Bx plus C. Now in this equation, A, B, and C
are all constants, and there's one more important restriction. A, this first
coefficient, is not allowed to be equal to 0. But why not? That is what I would
like you to tell me in this quiz. Why do you think A can't equal 0? If that
happened, would that stretch the parabola? Would it shift the parabola? Would it
flip the parabola upside down? Would the graph, instead of a parabola, become a
vertical line? Would it be a straight line instead? Or would the graph
completely disappear? Pick the explanation down here that you think is the best
choice.